steve morales um
there's a co-op
at the
corner
of my street it's nearest grocer um
can you promise that i'll be able to
walk to the corner and get sausages for
my stuffing
uh on christmas day
good morning trevor thanks for inviting
me on yes i can assure you that you will
get your stuffing at christmas time um
to coin a phrase um we're working very
hard to get all the christmas favorites
for our customers the members
and um and you should be reassured about
that
what i can say however is is that this
isn't a co-op problem uh it's not even a
national problem it's a global issue
one that isn't going to be fixed quickly
and will need real structural change
and as goods move across the world
they've become quite dislocated um from
its end use so
whilst the government's recent actions
around visas and extending time periods
is going to help there is no doubt
this will take some while to fix and
requires a real
change in mindset on how we move goods
around the globe
i'll come to that in a second but you
said back in august that the shortages
then were the worst that you had seen in
your time in in retail um
is that still the case today
yes we're still um seeing daily that the
challenges of this perfect storm a storm
that's affecting all retailers
all suppliers
and that is still with us here today
things are improving
not as fast as we would all like
but yes they continue to exist and
as i say
we're all working extremely hard to fix
the issue which is 90 000 hgv drivers
too short from what we all require
money is going to help but it's not the
answer here it requires a complete
rethink
and trevor as you know we've just
recently come out with one of the
largest post pandemic surveys around
young people and their life aspirations
who i think can be part of the solution
around the issues that that we're facing
today but worryingly they've told us
that they
sorry you're going to say something i
want to come to that i want to come to
the longer term issues but um
you you
mentioned the 90 000 uh drivers that uh
we need now the government has said in
effect this week several ministers has
made the same point that the shortage of
hgv drivers is down to you and your
fellow industry bosses because instead
of training our young people what you
did was mainline on immigrant labor
which was cheaper and eat more easily
available in essence
this
crisis is your fault
well i refute that completely um our
role as retailers is to provide
the best value for money that we can for
those people that come and shop with us
whilst um making sure that those that
serve us are well rewarded for their
efforts
um this has been uh an issue
that goes beyond retailing uh as far as
the demise and the number of uh drivers
across the uk
but again i i think that we have uh a
number of solutions in our grasp young
people will hopefully be one of those
well you're going to be here at the
conservative party conference this week
and i think you're making
the case uh for
uh greater skills training and so on um
what what are you going to be telling
the prime minister that he needs to do
well i think in in the same way i'm
saying the supply chain needs a
structural change
we're going to need if leveling up is
going to be successful um a real
structural approach to leveling up uh if
we want it to be better and fairer and
as i
referred to at the beginning
this recent survey is showing us that
the younger generation
can play a significant part in in that
agenda
but they are
disengaged and we need to listen to
their concerns and their life
aspirations
because they're telling us that they
have no hope
so what i'll be talking about is how
businesses like the co-op with
government and local leaders do need to
come together
to work on
solutions and pathways for young people
to achieve
their full potential and it shouldn't
matter where you come from trevor or
what color you are or what
gender or religion you have i i believe
that that all
young adults and students
need to have an equal chance in getting
on and and i think that will be
certainly a strong message that i'll be
giving